they're loud
they're bleak
and they come from Botswana
here in Bakken the sound of over thrust
goes down well
it's the musicians first trip outside of
Africa and they've headed straight to
the biggest metal festival in the world
this place is so metal everything is all
about metal and is the experience that
we've been looking forward to so it's
amazing it's a dream come true for us we
are now acting as an ambassadors for the
African metal not only our country but
now we are representing Africa the four
musicians come from dancing in the west
of the country they started their band
seven years ago
/ thrust make classic death metal an
especially grim variant of heavy metal
their songs deal with death purgatory
and false preachers Europeans may no
longer be shocked but people in their
home country of Botswana just don't get
it we didn't give up to over thrust we
just realized that okay fine maybe they
need a wisdom they need that kind of
education that maybe they have to
understand that metal rock or rock and
roll it's actually a music made with
fashion there's nothing to do with the
religion it's helped that the death
metal Cowboys put on a benefit concert
every year where they also collect
donations for an AIDS charity back to
Balkan over thrust camp out here
together with metal musicians from all
over the world media interest in the
death metal errs is huge as Ponce Moniz
hard rock scene is hardly known
internationally no generic on world it's
a good thing tool to know that we're
actually exchanging new cultures and
getting to know each other and through
metal scene people will be able to know
our country not only like in football
tournaments and another stop the over
thrust lead singer has made many
sacrifices for his dream he sold his
motorcycle to finance the band's
equipment
he's overjoyed that his band is now
playing in Germany
in metal is not about a mani or
something is about passion so we are
going to keep it that way
/ thrust our in Europe for a total of
three weeks with appearances in Zurich
calls Ron Essen and Hamburg Oh bro yeah